boa noite pessoal am
eu queria começar aqui mostrando pra
vocês
romã é uma gravura do século 14 que
mostra o que é uma aula universitária é
o que é uma aula dentro de uma
universidade
embora muitos possam dizer que essa é a
gravura é antiga
ela continua representando a nossa
estrutura é de ensino ea o formato como
é a aas as informações são passadas
dentro do ambiente de uma universidade
então claramente a gente consegue
identificar alguns atores aqui nessa
gravura
a gente tem aqui nesse caso o professor
no seu pedestal onipotente onipresente
passando a sua informação a gente tem
nos nos círculos verdes
aqui o pessoal lá da frente o pessoal
está todo interessado na aula está
prestando atenção no professor
depois a gente tem nos círculos amarelos
o pessoal está fazendo alguma outra
coisa eles não não tão distraídos mas
também não estão concentrados eles são o
pessoal do meio da da turma é o pessoal
tem o pessoal da frente o pessoal do
meio e a gente tem
já no século 14 o pessoal do fundão é
como a gente pode ver é lá em cima tem
um interessado na menina o outro outros
dois conversando e aqui em baixo no
canto o carinho dormindo aqui há um que
é uma coisa clássica dentro é
descendente de aulas é essa palestra
está interessada no cara dormindo
é o que eu vim aqui falar pra vocês é
será que é possível a gente salvar esse
cara que tá dormindo e aí eu quero
passar para vocês uma 11 mostrar uma das
técnicas e que o tablet usando a minha
disciplina de estrutura de dar
a computação para tentar salvar esse
cara
obviamente que levando em conta que o
professor é uma pessoa extremamente
ocupada
o professor gosta muito do cara que tá
lá na frente ele tolera o cara que está
ali no meio e normalmente ele não tá nem
aí pro cara lá do fundo
o professor tem um monte de coisa pra
fazer o professor dá aula mas participa
de congressos câmeras de ensino ué viaja
para conferências tem uma série de
coisas acontecendo
a professora extremamente ocupado ele
tem vida né aqui está o grande exemplo
de vida de professor
há no entanto a gente vê que é uma
grande preocupação quando você está
ensinando é essa pessoa que perde o
interesse aqui ela não teve exatamente
aquela aquela motivação e isso gera um
impacto muito grande no curso de
computação a gente tem turmas com
reprovação aí na casa de 50 a 60% da
turma reprova é no semestre e dando aula
eu percebi que existem alguns focos de
por que isso acontece
não então a pessoa perde a motivação ela
deixa de ir pra aula quando ela deixa de
ir pra aula deixando de participar
e quando eu deixei de participar começa
a ouvir os resultados ruins e isso tudo
leva a um grande problema pra gente que
é o problema da evasão escolar é o nosso
curso provavelmente um dos cursos que
mais tem razão dentro da ufsc e não e
não é pouco é bastante gente todo mundo
acha que fazer computação sistemas de
informação é você ficar no facebook e
brincar na internet ou assistir vídeos
no youtube e na verdade é bem diferente
a gente chame gente é matemática
aplicada
aí eu me fiz a pergunta será que a gente
consegue mudar esse modelo a gente
consegue mudar esse modelo do século 14
que perdura até hoje
então qual seria o custo disso que a
gente teria que mudar qualquer grande
estratégia pra pra isso
ah e eu acabei vendo que o dentro de si
nesse modelo uma das coisas que funciona
extremamente bem
é quando a gente tem uma tutoria um
contato entre o professor eo aluno que é
uma coisa meio que abolida nesse
ambiente universitário e só que
obviamente tem seus motivos não é como
eu já falei o professor é um cara
extremamente ocupado então eu comecei a
olhar e se tentar propor modelos mudar a
dinâmica didático pedagógica das minhas
disciplinas para tentar fazer o quê
tenta criar um modelo de tutoria
um-para-um que ao mesmo tempo ajudar sua
aluna seguindo passo dele e me liberasse
para fazer todas as outras atividades
que eu tenho que fazer além de dar aula
então é eu vou andando usando como
exemplo que a disciplina de estrutura de
dados é é uma disciplina que dentro do
curso de computação ela é a uma
disciplina extremamente prática que tem
que ensinar para uma habilidades básicas
para o exercício da profissão então por
ser uma disciplina extremamente prática
é uma disciplina onde que a luta tem que
fazer muitos trabalhos práticos e fazer
muitos trabalhos práticos significa que
ou o professor assume que está tudo
feito
o professor pede para que o aluno
entregue o trabalho e ele tem que sentar
e corrigir isso tudo significa investir
tempo pra vocês terem uma idéia num
semestre de 18 semanas em na nossa
disciplina de escultura de dados
a gente tem 12 trabalhos de programação
para ser entregues um por semana
desses 12 trabalhos a gente tem 6 a 6
um grande trabalho que vale uma nota uma
boa parte da nota e também é a gente tem
uma prova teórica e uma prova prática
o que significa isso significa que é
propor ensino dessa disciplina prática
ou eu vou utilizar alguma estratégia ou
ficar completamente maluco e aí seguindo
esse esse ideal do essa frase que está
aqui do einstein é que a gente quer ver
mudança a gente tem que mudar alguma
coisa é eu percebi que eu teria que
fazer alguma alguma mudança no conceito
usual de quim
se você quer dar trabalho como é que
corrigir - trabalhos você cria grupos
quanto maior for o grupo de alunos menor
o número de trabalhos e tem corrigido
quanto menos questão estiver na prova
mais rápido você corrige uma prova e
isso tudo tem um impacto no modelo é
didático pedagógico neowin o que o aluno
vai efetivamente aprender e o que ele
vai demonstrar em uma disciplina prática
isso fica extremamente evidente então eu
decidir é partir para o uso de uma
tecnologia para me assistir
é eu passei a utilizar um sistema de
gerenciamento de conteúdo que talvez
muitos de vocês já conheçam mas tentei
utilizar e de um formato diferente aonde
que ele não é simplesmente uma
plataforma de entrega de conteúdo mas
ele é meu assistente para trabalhar as
entregas as cobranças tudo o que tem a
ver com a disciplina
então o que a gente vai o que eu quero
mostrar aqui pra vocês são os três
os três grandes focos que eu tive
utilizando essa plataforma de apoio ao
ensino
a omd que ele passa por um controle
total da disciplina uma automatização da
disciplina o aluno tem todo um modelo de
prodi de automação provas e entrega de
trabalhos baseados dentro dessa
ferramenta a o primeiro foco com que eu
percebi é que boa parte das das
repetências né das reprovações que eu
tenho na minha disciplina
elas estão diretamente ligadas a não
presença é o aluno começa a perder o
interesse
falta e quanto mais ele faltam menos
interesse e vai ter então uma das partes
do processo de automação que eu coloquei
na disciplina foi passar a fazer a
chamada fazer o controle de freqüência
através dessa ferramenta ea partir daí
eu tenho um acesso online eu sei por
exemplo o próprio sistema auxilia nisso
me dizendo olha o aluno faltou duas
altas seguidas o que eu faço eu vou
mandar uma mensagem para o aluno e
pergunto pra ele que está acontecendo
pois vezes é é alguma coisa às vezes a
perda
ele perdeu o interesse e só essa
cutucadinha esse toque no aluno é o
suficiente para reacender ele é outras
coisas é que quando é freqüente
se achegando abaixo do que deveria nem
do ponto de vista das normativas da
universidade
eu comuniquei a ele que ele está ele
está pronto para perder o jogo e isso
também entende é reativar o que eu vi é
que a partir do momento que eu passei a
utilizar esse tipo de estratégia e
reduzir o número de reprovações por
freqüência suficiente nas minhas
disciplinas uma turma de 50 alunos eu
tinha em média de 10 a 12 reprovações
por freqüência suficiente e conseguir
reduzir para duas neste semestre
então é uma estratégia razoavelmente
interessante o fato do aluno saber que
existe alguém fiscalizando ele existe
alguém cuidando e eu não tenho nenhum
trabalho mais pra fazer isso eu
simplesmente têm a ferramenta que
auxilia o segundo grande foco que eu
tenho no uso da ferramenta é a aplicação
de provas
utilizando o ambiente é o esse ambiente
virtual
então o que a gente fez foi criar um
banco de questões onde as questões estão
classificadas por conteúdo e por grau de
dificuldade e nesse nessa aplicação da
prova
a gente passa a utilizar um modelo não é
com laboratório de informática aonde que
os alunos vão passar a ter é provas
individualizados então eu não tenho mais
que me preocupar com qualquer
subterfúgio do aluno não é eu tenho um
banco lá com 140 questões que o sorteio
esses dois alunos pegaram a mesma
questão elas podem embaralhar o a ou as
respostas e assim por diante então é uma
coisa muito interessante é que a coisa
mais importante desse modelo desse
segundo foco são as estatísticas que eu
tenho um acesso é direto dentro da data
da aplicação da prova então eu sei por
exemplo quais foram as questões que
foram mais erradas quais as questões que
avaliam melhor quais as que não avaliam
bem e eu consegui inclusive avaliar o
meu processo didático
quando eu vejo que uma turma é erra por
exemplo é só 23% da minha turma certo um
determinado tipo de questão onde tem
oito questões mas só é indiferente da
questão a turma toda não conseguiu
assimilar aquele conteúdo eu sei que eu
tenho que melhorar eu me candidate
exatamente naquele ponto a isso é uma
das coisas
a gente consegue um feedback muito
importante dos alunos é que eles vêem
isso como um sistema muito justo porque
perde toda aquela história ela
pessoalidade naquela à vontade talvez do
professor ajudar o aluno ou não
então é uma coisa muito importante e o
terceiro foco na condução da da minha
disciplina de estrutura de dados é a
entrega de trabalhos a eu tento utilizar
o modelo construtivista aonde que o
aluno pode lhe entregar o trabalho
receber um feedback e entregar esse
trabalho
obviamente que eu fosse fazer isso em
com as visuais agente passaria a ter um
grande problema é porque o aluno gosta
de entregar o trabalho de madrugada o
aluno gosta de ter a resposta o quanto
antes possível
é dentro dessa ferramenta de apoio
ensino conseguiu desenvolver um modelo
onde o aluno vá lá me entrego trabalho o
trabalho é avaliado automaticamente
sugestões são dadas por aluno para que
ele corrija esse trabalho e nesse
processo de aprendizado
o aluno vai ter um feedback instantâneo
ele vai poder corrigir o poder me
entregar de novo então o aluno só pára
de me entregar o trabalho quando ele
está satisfeito com a nota que lhe tirou
então pra vocês terem uma idéia no
semestre onde eu não apliquei essa
metodologia a média de nota dos
trabalhos variava de 5 a 7
eu tive trabalho semestre por exemplo
onde toda a turma tirou 10
obviamente teve gente que entregou duas
ou três vezes e fez duas ou três
avaliações eram alunos que entregaram 56
vezes isso é isso é significativo é um
processo de aprendizado contínuo é bom
pro sumariza aqui pra vocês é eu
acredito que é possível a gente salvar
aquele aluno que está desinteressada que
tá com a chama da vontade de aprender
delilah apagando a gente talvez com uma
pequena cutucada nele e com o processo
que demonstre que é imparcial e que é
instantâneo e que é capaz de mostrar pra
ele o caminho certo a gente consegue
criar um processo formativo que não
torna a disciplina porque uma outra
estratégia seria tornar a disciplina
extremamente
então eu faço de conta que eu ensino o
aluno faz de conta que aprende e no
final todo mundo feliz
obviamente que isso não leva a um modelo
de bons profissionais
então o meu grande resultado é que eu
consigo eu conseguir reduzir em quase
80% o número de reprovações nas minhas
turmas ou seja o presente semestre é
passado onde eu não adotei esse modelo
completo
eu tive a média do meu departamento
então eu estava completamente dentro da
média ou seja uma turma de 38 alunos com
18 reprovações e se essa infelizmente
essa é a média dentro do departamento de
computação este semestre
numa turma com 44 alunos porque eu tive
que pegar aqueles que lhes 18 do
semestre anterior
eu eu tive uma uma média de reprovação
não eu tive duas reprovações por
freqüência suficiente a onde os alunos
inclusive eram se justificar para mim
dizendo dizendo os problemas que eles
tiveram e eu tive mais seis reprovações
por nota a onde obviamente os alunos não
atingir os objetivos mas eles estão
completamente cientes do que eles
deveriam ter feito e como eles poderiam
atingir isso e eu quero dizer para vocês
o seguinte é esse modelo o modelo é
inclusivo e que ele não ajuda só ele não
pensasse esse retorno humanístico não
adianta tentar ajudar essa pessoa estava
perdida mas ele é um ele tem um retorno
financeiro directo própria universidade
é quanto menos gente ficar repetindo aí
mais espaço tem para outras pessoas
era isso que eu tinha para dizer pra
vocês pessoal obrigado